hi everybody i'm josh welsh president of
film independent and welcome to the 2022
film independent spirit awards
nominations announcement we are so
excited to be able to share this year's
slate of nominees with you visionary
storytellers working across film and
television for the past several months
our nominating committees have been hard
at work watching eligible shows and
films from
2021 at the spirit awards we look for
uniqueness of vision original
provocative subject matter economy of
means and diversity both on screen and
off at film independent we champion
creative independence and visual
storytelling and we support a community
of filmmakers and film lovers who share
those values this year of our nominated
writers and directors i'm proud to share
that 44 are women and 38 are bipod and
of our nominating committee members who
worked so hard to reach today's
nominations 63 identify as women 5
percent is non-binary and 56 as bipac
this year we had almost 50 dedicated
filmmakers and film lovers who spent
months watching and fiercely debating
almost 650 films and series a record
number fiction and non-fiction american
and international in order to arrive at
today's nominations i'd like to take a
moment to thank this year's incredible
partners our premier sponsor ifc
our official spirits bullet frontier
whiskey and seedlip and our official
water fiji water we so appreciate your
support and devotion to the independent
community we are so happy the spirit
awards are going to be back in person on
the beach in santa monica once again the
show will be broadcast on ifc
not on the saturday before the oscars
but on sunday march 6th so please tune
in one last note about the spirit awards
for anyone who might be new to this the
winners of the spirit awards are chosen
by film independent members film
independent is an open access
organization that welcomes filmmakers
and film lovers alike no matter who you
are or where you live if you care about
great storytelling we want you as a
member in order to vote this year please
join by december the 21st
you'll get screeners of nominated films
and shows but most importantly you will
become part of the community that votes
to determine the winners of the 2022
film independence spirit awards please
join me in welcoming our three amazing
presenters this morning beanie feldstein
regina hall and naomi watts naomi take
it away
hi everyone and welcome to the spirit
awards one of my favorite award
ceremonies i have many great memories
being there in that room amongst so many
of my peers and feeling so proud to be
there i do remember the 21 grams
audience award most of all and that was
one of the most memorable experiences
for me so getting over to the nominees
in the category of best screen play
come on come
on the lost daughter
swan song
together together
and zola the nominees in the category of
best cinematography are
chiara
blue bayou
the humans
passing
and zola nominees in the category of
best documentary are
ascension
flee
in in the same breath
procession
summer of soul
or when the revolution could not be
televised
the nominees in the category of best
first feature are
seven days
holler
queen of glory
test pattern
wild indian
the nominees in the category of best
supporting male are
coleman domingo
zola
miko gattuso
queen of glory
troy kotzer
will patton
sweet thing
chucksey spencer
wild indian
the nominees in the category of best
male lead are
clifton collins jr
jockey
frankie faison the killing of kenneth
chamberlain
michael grahaes
wild indian
udo kier
swansong
and simon rex
red rocket
the nominees for the john cassavetes
award are
cryptozoo jockey
shiva baby
sweet thing
and this is not a war story
this year's robert altman award which is
given to one film's director casting
director and ensemble cast
mass
director fran krantz
casting directors henry russell
bergstein alison estrin
ensemble cast kagan albright reed bernie
michelle n carter
and dowd
jason isaacs
martha plimpton
breeda wool
regina over to you
thank you so much naomi now the nominee
in the category of best first screenplay
are
cicada
mass
pig
test pattern and wild indian the
nominees in the category of best editing
are
akita
the killing of kenneth chamberlain
the novice
the nowhere in
and zola
the nominees in the category of best
international film are
compartment number six finland
drive my car japan
parallel mothers spain
pebbles
india
petite mama
france
prayers for the stolen mexico the
nominees in the category of best
supporting female are
jesse buckley the lost daughter
amy forsythe the novice
ruth nega passing
ravika and rousselle
pleasure
susannah sun
red rocket
the nominees in the category of best
female lead are
isabel furman the novice
britney s hall test pattern
patty harrison together together
taylor page
zola
kaylee reese
catch the fair one the nominees in the
category of best director are
janiksa bravo zola
maggie gyllenhaal the lost daughter
lauren hattaway the novice
mike mills come on come on
ninja thyberg pleasure the nominees in
the category of best feature are
a chiara
come on come on
the lost
daughter the novice
and zola
now beanie over to you
thank you so much regina let's start
with the emerging filmmaker award
categories each of these awards
recognizes emerging filmmakers who have
not yet received the appropriate
recognition each emerging filmmaker
award comes with an unrestricted grant
of 25 000
the truer than fiction award is
presented to a talented director of
non-fiction features the finalists are
jessica beshear director of faya dei
debi lum director of try harder
angelo madsen minax director of north by
current the someone to watch award
honors a talented filmmaker of singular
vision the finalists are
alex camilleri director of luzu
jillian wallace horvat director of i
blame society
michael cernovsky director of pig the
producers award which is given to an
emerging producer who despite highly
limited resources demonstrates the
creativity tenacity and vision required
to produce quality independent films the
finalists are
brad becker parton pinchon liu
lizzie shapiro
here are the nominees in tv series for
the spirit awards
the nominees in the category of best new
scripted series are
blind spotting
it's a sin
reservation dogs the underground
railroad we are lady parts
the nominees in the category of best new
non-scripted or documentary series are
black and missing the cho show
the lady and the dale
nuclear family
philly d.a
the nominees in the category of best
male performance in a new scripted
series are
ali alexander it's a sin
murray bartlett the white lotus
michael grey eyes rutherford falls
lee jong-jae squid game
ashley thomas them covenant best female
performance in a new scripted series are
deborah irinde them covenant
jasmine cephas jones blind spotting
tusso and baidu the underground railroad
jenna schmeeding rutherford falls
anjana vossen we are lady parts
and finally the best ensemble cast in a
new scripted series is awarded to
reservation dogs ensemble cast paulina
alexis
lane factor funny bone devilry jacobs
zahn mclaren lil mike
sarah podemski and deferra lunatai
congratulations to all the nominees
today and remember only film independent
members vote for the winners of the
spirit awards so to become a member
visit
filmindependent.org and join today and
don't forget tune in on our new date
sunday march 6 back at the beach in
santa monica
thank you beanie and thank you naomi and
regina congratulations again to all of
our nominees and remember please join
film independent and vote for the
winners of the spirit awards in 2022 and
don't forget tune in on our new date and
time sunday march 6 on ifc
thanks for watching and see you on the
beach
[Music]
you